boulevard lafayette près du pont jacques
cartier
trois maisons voisines plutôt charmante
et en assez bon état qui dans quelques
semaines seront démolis un promoteur les
a achetés et s'apprête à construire des
condos comme sur les terrains voisins où
les anciennes maisons ont subi le même
sort
puis le plus jeune vendeur d'honneur
gilles demers était propriétaire d'une
des trois maisons
il a accepté de vendre à contrecoeur et
a déjà déménagé de toutes façons on
n'était pas de la vente un moment donné
parce que solide 7 1
les le journal permet la construction de
plex sur sa rue comme dans plusieurs
secteurs de longueuil un peu partout les
nouvelles constructions poussent sans
trop de contraintes réglementaires
un groupe de citoyens a même créé un
compte facebook pour dénoncer la
situation
trousser trophée a été un feu claquent
de mission de la maison sur la rue grant
mais juste un phénomène qui me dérange
et ça phénomène qu'on voyait grande
synthe qui s'est accélérée de façon
incroyable cette année on se sent
menacée dans notre environnement par une
des lois du remède des règlements
d'urbanisme qui sont incohérents la
sensibilisation à porter fruit la ville
annoncé mardi qu elle encadrera mieux la
construction de plex dans l'avenir
eagle cadre réglementaire des règlements
qu'on va vouloir mettre en place qui
après sa belle la réflexion peut-être un
comité de démolition pour être mis en
place pour dire ben on va regarder
chacun des projets pizza est ce que est
ce que c'est ça qu'on souhaite qu'ils
arrivent à cette maison long en
attendant avec la rareté des terrains et
le boom immobilier à longueuil
le phénomène se poursuit c'est une
lettre qui me proposent d'acheter la
moitié de mon terrain pour construire
une maison
ça arrive souvent que je recevais ça
j'en reçois presque toutes les semaines
maintenant dominique ouzzine on ne
souhaite jamais vendre sa belle
propriété du secteur lemoyne et les
contente de l'annnonce de la ville mais
reste prudente
je vais le croire quand je vais le where
minimum ça prend un moratoire il faut
arrêter de donner des permis le temps
d'étudier
qu'est ce que sera le plan d'urbanisme
est en révision se plaint sylvie parent
n'imposera pas de moratoire mais répond
qu'elle fera vite pour améliorer la
réglementation la maison verte et
blanche de gilles demers aura le temps
d'être démolie je peux même pas pour
seul programme va y aller parce que
c'est sur ta vie et sa vie est un petit
morceau d'histoire de longueuil ici
jean-sébastien cloutier radio canada
longueuil